if you grew up with him he grew on you
Glen Campbell was everything from but
now what's glittering maybe a tear
rather than a rhinestone because Glen
Campbell suffering from Alzheimer's has
released his last saw I'm stood here
because if he's singing to his wife Kim
being here when CNN interviewed Glen the
year he was diagnosed what they
diagnosed me is Alzheimer's Alzheimer's
what's all Alzheimer mm-hmm is you start
losing your memory a year or so after
that interview Glen recorded this last
song January of 2013 the video
juxtaposes brain scans and happy home
movies Glen's things to camp
best
not gonna miss you not gonna miss you
because his memory is missing the song
was released in advance of a documentary
this knowing that the doors always open
I'll be me focuses on Glenn's goodbye
tour when he used a teleprompter to
remember lyrics it's a loving ss5 so my
timeline but Frank will get the multi
Grammy Award winner fighting a battle he
couldn't win your difficulties are due
to Alzheimer's he famously sang of
memory by the rivers of my memories he
keeps you ever just alone
but there's nothing gentle on the mind
about Alzheimer's about six months ago
Glen Campbell was admitted to a special
care facility in Nashville he may no
longer remember but at least fans of one
last song to remember him by
my Jeanne Moos CNN on my New York